bricks is on a path of expansion but
there's been little progress in deciding
who will make the cut after two days of
meetings in Cape Town at the moment the
group's made up of five countries Brazil
Russia India China and South Africa at
least 19 countries including Saudi
Arabia Iran and Gabon have expressed
interest in joining the Bloc for many
it's emerged as an alternative to
Western dominance and potentially
providing a counterbalance to the West
it's a kind of a slightly and building
sort of organization because I think it
likes to see itself as non-aligned but
you know if in increasing polarized
world that we earn at the moment where
Russia and the and the West NATO are at
each other's throats you know to have
one of those
polls of the new conflict that is
already a brics member creates a
complication there
it's planned for a common currency for
trade within the block has not been
finalized and for now once to increase
trade among its member states in their
local currencies ultimately reducing
Reliance on the US dollar
South Africa's foreign affairs minister
Nar lady Pando says the group is hoping
for more cooperation we also looked at I
think an important subject which is what
are the links that there should be
between bricks and G20 in an
increasingly in our view multi-polar
world we we have a sense
that we're moving away
from a unipolar and this increasing
interest in multi-polarity so how do we
draw together
these are formations that have a number
of shared ideals and goals as countries
around the world recover from the impact
of the pandemic and the global economy
remains in distress leaders here say the
growing brics new development bank will
continue to provide support to programs
to end poverty but as the block looks to
expand some say members like South
Africa and Brazil may be concerned their
influence could be reduced and that the
group May lack a clear identity and
unified policy
Cape Town